hi there steve here
um today i want to talk about you know
two things really one i'm going to
announce my upcoming trip to
latin america just in case uh
some of you are going to be there so for
the month of october i'm going to be the
first essentially 10 11 days
in argentina
uh mostly in buenos aires also in
mendoza
the second 10 11 days 10 days i'm in
brazil based in rio and then two days in
salvador
and then the third day third
third of the month i'm in peru
going to machu picchu and then
the last four or five days or so hanging
around lima
so i if anybody wants to meet up there
please let me know
and this is kind of
the theme today is how you know
once we've invested time in a language
and reached a certain level
then we may slip
but we have it and we have it there and
we can enjoy it so
for example
in preparation for my trip to latin
america i'm not going to do anything
special to refresh my spanish or refresh
my portuguese
it'll be what it is when i get there and
it'll be better on day two than it is on
day one
spanish is basically a language that i
can turn on fairly easily but i may have
to get used to the the form of spanish
that's spoken in argentina we will see
and brazilian or these portuguese is a
language that i put a little bit of
effort into it was harder than i thought
it wasn't an automatic slam dunk from
spanish
and i speak a kind of portugal
mixture of spanish and portuguese but i
suspect that after the first day or two
in brazil
my portuguese will improve and the 10
days that i spend there will very much
improve my portuguese and then i'm back
into spanish again but it reminds me
that that the work that i put into these
languages i you know i get it back
without having to worry about what i can
produce you know on the spot when sort
of challenged to demonstrate
my ability in the language so another
example of that is
recently you know my wife always tries
to attract me away from my language
learning in the evening after dinner i'm
working on my arabic i'm now into
political podcasts where i'm looking up
every word or every second word but
still i think because i'm getting these
podcasts transcribed and i'm working
through them on link and saving words
and reviewing words and listening again
slowly that's giving me
a better and better sense of the
language although of course the amount
of vocabulary there is is tremendous
that i have to learn
but i've done it for other languages so
i just know it's a matter of time
but recently she says oh steve there's
this tremendous spanish movie on so we
watched la catedral del mar
uh which was very very interesting
series
about barcelona and in the 14th century
and stuff like that
and then no sooner are we off that
then she says steve there's a russian
movie on so i go up there and they have
this the road to calvary which is
something in in russian
but it's about you know the first world
war and the civil war in russia and
stuff like that and very well done and
of course
the joy for me in both these situations
is that i'm able to understand them
and so that um yeah the work that i put
into learning those languages
gives me now the ability to understand
and to enjoy those languages so
we learn these languages yeah certainly
to communicate and i will be
communicating in these languages when
i'm in latin america and spanish in
portuguese
or if i were in russia you know and
you know watch the movie and there are
scenes in rostov or in samara and saint
petersburg and you said geez wouldn't be
wouldn't it be great to go there and
talk to people and stuff but
even if you can't do that you can enjoy
the languages that you have put great
effort into learning you can enjoy them
by watching tv series by watching movies
by reading books listening to podcasts
as not as i'm now you know
embarking on doing in arabic and maybe
in a year from now i'll be able to
fully understand political discussions
in arabic which is certainly not the
case right now and be able to read you
know al jazeera
uh you know website articles and end up
with a very different perspective on
the relationship between the west and
the arab world
uh
so
i just wanted to announce then my trip
to latin america
and just reaffirm that
you know there are many sort of reasons
for wanting to learn languages and just
discover
different people different culture
different histories
and
just communicating with people at some
very basic level is not
everyone's goal although that's perhaps
a valid goal if you're traveling
somewhere as a tourist
but that every effort that we put into
these languages gives us a greater
understanding of
and the ability to access other cultures
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you